Hey there.
Welcome to the first practice set.
After every lesson, you're going
to have practice sets with me
to review what you learned in
the lesson, and make some cool stuff.
I bring four practice exercises to
instill what you've learned so far.
So first,
you're going to install Android Studio,
which is a program that professional
developers use to make Android apps.
Following that, you'll make
your very first Android app and
load it up on your phone.
Once you're done with that,
I'm going to walk you through how to
make a simple birthday card application.
Finally, you'll make you
own custom card app and
show other students your design process.
Well, no time like
the present to get started.
So grab a cup of coffee [SOUND]
and get to code.